michael smith of brother from another
along with michael holly follows this
program every single day on nbc sports
on peacock and i always love chopping it
up with michael yeah
and he joins us now here on the rich
eisen show how you doing michael
good
enjoying your conversation speaking of
twitter did you see what uh shepherd
tweeted two minutes ago uh i don't
believe so what is he what do you tweet
to me last week antonio brown and his
agent requested that the remaining two
million dollars in incentives in his
contract for the season be guaranteed
per bucks gm jason light the team
declined to guarantee those incentives
well and then now
look man here's the thing
with antonio brown with antonio brown in
the history because again i have the
history i've got those receipts as well
it always is something to do with this
contract that sparks it it did it in
pittsburgh he got to
uh oakland at the time
and they gave him his money that was the
weird thing about all that is that that
was about whatever the hell that was
about and then the patriots thing was
about not having his back now this is
about money and all of it winds up on
his instagram account or his twitter
account when it doesn't go his way
and uh
information i saw that too look i i'll
just give you the floor on the subject
matter and what what you think of the
saga because it is a spectacle
michael i'll just give you the floor on
that what do you think of it
i think guys after last night and i read
antonio brown's statement several times
um
you want to talk about there will be
lawyers this is a pretty easy
investigation because there was some
subjectivity and some of his
perspective on what transpired on the
sideline and how he was feeling how hurt
he was but there was also some things
that were objectively provable with a
paper trail
um and you saw
his version of that paper trail this
morning
uh with some of the
alleged text messages that he released i
would just point out
i would just point out
that
this is the same person
who not only faked his vaccination
status
but when he was busted
faked
or staged rather
a both
being vaccinated a nurse and a clinic
like staged the uh the cover-up
that he was vaccinated and trying
in the process of trying to prove that
he did not fake his vaccination status
and was and that he was in fact
vaccinated produced a fake nurse and
clinic to support it
so i say all that to say this
all that we know right now is that we
don't know we know
that we know not
actually i'll amend that
the one thing we do know all of us know
about antonio brown
is that it always ends badly
it's just a matter of how
now to your point about this binary
world we live in and i've been talking
about this for the last couple of days
because when the conversation around
antonio brown
um
got toward the mental health space
you have people on one side and it's
really just representative of how we
talk as a society you have people on one
side that we're dug in on this guy's a
knucklehead this guy's a clown this
guy's a jerk look at his track record
stop making excuses for him
any other people on the other side that
were like pray for antonio brown this is
clearly a cry for help he needs help
he hasn't
bring that together there's like there's
a middle ground there it could be a
combination of both things more than one
thing can be true
likewise for the bucks
could the bucks have been the latest
example of a team enabling him for the
sake of taking advantage of his talent
and therefore needed to be held
accountable
themselves
and
could they
have just had enough and said enough is
enough
even if he does need help said you know
what we've done all we can here more
than one thing can again be true so now
fast forward to today that was when it
was just about mental health
and what antonio brown is
may or may not i stress may or may not
be dealing with emotionally or
psychologically so now fast forward to
today
same thing same dynamic is at play here
and tj that's true speaking to of on
social media same dynamic as that play
i'd be willing to bet that the majority
of the people who are going at bruce
arians
we're already predisposed to defending
antonio brown
and i'll bet that the majority of the
people who are discrediting antonio
brown's version of events
were already predisposed to being sick
of his act
so nothing that happened last night is
probably going to move people from their
side of the aisle like either the easier
you're standing with antonio brown more
than likely i'm not saying it's 100
or you're sick of antonio brown
and so
said on that sideline we may never know
what was said on that sideline the truth
more than likely as usual lies somewhere
in the middle
and that's that nuance y'all are talking
about which is
increasingly
scarce
in our dialogues that it's probably
you know both sides probably are telling
some version of the truth one guy's
credibility
is that issue one guy has a track record
of dysfunction
and that doesn't help him but that
doesn't mean he's completely lying here
or lying at all he could be telling the
truth in this instance that's that cry
wolf um reference you made earlier
on the other hand
did the bucks do everything right
maybe maybe not
but i go back to the larger point which
this was always going to end badly
because it always does with antonio
brown michael smith of brother from
another on peacock uh nbc sports on
peacock follows our show every single
every single day uh how do you think the
kyrie irving return ends
how do you think it ends i have my two
cents i'd like to hear yours i think he
ends up getting the shot
now last night he
seemed like he was very uh he was a lot
of uh
uh you know passive verbs or he seemed
to suggest that i hope it works out and
you know it almost suggests that he
hopes that like the mandate is lifted or
you know that's not happening right you
know what i mean but he seemed to kind
of put it off as if it was somebody
else's decision as to whether or not he
could play you know as if he had nothing
to do with it you know but i think
the more the season goes on it's going
to be really and as the stakes get
higher it's one thing to miss 35 regular
season games as the stakes get higher i
think it's gonna be harder for him
to be a part-time player and i think as
the playoffs roll around i i think he
ends up
getting the shot he's proved his point
he's still on his principle
the nets have have met him halfway by
allowing him to be a part-time player i
don't see him sitting out
uh
a home playoff game because he's
unvaccinated given especially given how
well he was received
by the team last night um
yeah i i think it i think it's actually
relatively speaking a happy ending in
brooklyn as it relates to kyrie's
vaccinations well i i hope you're right
michael uh i'm i'm taking the other
approach and and his comments about as
you pointed out him thinking it's really
someone else's decision uh points to
that that that he won't do it
and he
will uh do what we saw last night he's
so good man
he's so good think him do you think him
being allowed back makes him more
emboldened to not get the shot yes
i do
i think so because the net said
a few weeks and months ago yeah we this
is not workable now it's suddenly
workable
and not only workable it worked last
night all you had to do was
poor lance stevenson right i mean what
what a big game he had last night 20 in
the first 30 overall i know and we're
you know it's kind of like yeah too bad
kyrie came back too and that's
difference right because kyrie came back
if kyra wasn't there i think we'd be
talking about lance stevenson today so
on and so forth yeah and rightfully so
that was you know fun to watch fun to
see already stay ready ain't got to get
ready so but last night um
you know kyrie showed you what this team
could be and look like and i already saw
on twitter that people are are are in
line with what i think his plan is ball
out and then say
the mandate's unfair
and it's not
the reason why that he's not playing is
not the choice
uh his choice it's the choice of new
york city in their draconian public
health measures like that's the way it's
going to go that's the way it's
absolutely going to go this is just like
i was saying about antonio brown same
way people looked at it before
i i th the talking points haven't
changed as far as i can tell i just feel
like the reason i'm optimistic and i'm
optimistic to a fault oftentimes
is that
this is easy to talk about when the
stakes ain't that high
you know it's the regular season
you know it's with just in the 2022
there's going to be more pressure and
antonio excuse me on kyrie irving
internally
both in terms of
his teammates who he purports to love
and care about
and who care about him and who has
supported him
the organization that he's a part of
as well as i'd like to think the
competitor that
kyrie irving is
and look man kyrie irving is is is the
last cinema we can see he's the last one
standing
there he wasn't the only one in the
preseason
that
didn't want to get vaccinated
andrew wiggins ended up getting
vaccinated he did
we'll see what novak djokovic ends up
doing i don't know
who knows but i think when it comes time
to pursue a championship
i think it's going to be harder for
kyrie to continue to stand on this
principle
whatever principle that is
yeah i i i understand that and the the
difficulty will be
him saying you know he doesn't stand for
anti-vaxx and he doesn't stand for but
what he stands for is his freedom to
choose and new york city is the problem
not his choice but he's already got his
out though he's already got his out see
he's he's also always said i am not
excuse me he said i am not anti-vaxxed
i am not a co-vic conspiracist
conspiracy theorist that's what he has
said well he's going to earn it because
again because it's honestly this is the
way it's going to go man we already saw
again as you pointed out just yesterday
uh with the australian open uh it just
so happened that the prime minister of
australia cited on the side of their
mandates and their
their
approach correct and and and the people
who have been living under that approach
were like why we make an exception for
him right i'm just wondering how the
folks in new york city will react if the
nets um need the the you know the extra
help at home because we we looked at it
i mean there's going to be a partner the
last four games he can't play one of
them's at the knicks the other three are
at home the last four games of the
season he can't play there's certain
stretches we're like we're not going to
see him for another five days now and if
they struggle at home and we come like
this is going to just build steam and i
honestly i i hope i am wrong and i'd
love to just talk about the x's and o's
of it i'd love to see kyrie irving play
the entire time
but you know uh for those who live in a
city where the mode of transportation to
getting around is in a tube or in a bus
mostly and where most housing is where
people live literally on top of each
other
this is the way
that they need to have
an approach towards battling kovid and
he
won't take the shot and i'm saying that
it will wind up being the conversation
you already see the media even described
like even though there was a tweet
yesterday in the daily beast like you
know djokovic won't take the shot
australia tells him to take the shot we
don't know how this can uh be fixed well
yeah
one guy could take the shot well no it's
simple and that's what i'm saying the
pressure is going to build on him he's
not going to win
he's not going to win in a battle
against a state and local government
mandate what i'm saying is he has
already given himself an out
because he's he said from the beginning
this is an ongoing process i don't know
what other facts he needs i don't know
what other so-called research he needs
to do
but kyrie irving is in position to be
able to for whatever it's worth to him
save face
kyrie irving can get the shot
and simply say i needed time
and it doesn't make him a sellout it
doesn't mean that he caved in and gave
in to the man it doesn't mean
you know that that that he lacks
conviction or whatever he can because he
never said i'm anti-vaxxed even though
his behavior suggested that he's
anti-vaxx
he seemed to be anti-vaccine mandate at
the end of this rich and i hear
everything you're saying i believe he's
going to come around and his explanation
is going to be
i had to go through my process and i
arrived at a place where i was
comfortable taking the shot even though
there's very little if any further
information about the of the safety and
efficacy of the vaccines than there were
before well i hope you're right michael
because i would like to have
in this pandemic you know that sports
bubble that's what i try to create here
every day unfortunately gets pierced by
the vaccine conversations and covered
you know diagnoses and things like that
i'd rather just have a conversation and
watch the big three play with each other
and
last year before last night wasn't that
a treat it was i'd love he's so
good he's gifted man and he's so and he
he's exactly what they need he's exactly
the guy yeah it's amazing how it works
sometimes that durant is is you know
the best player in the world you know i
think we can say that right now and hard
and harden harden has you know for
somebody so good his
his flaws
that that kyrie fills in when the two of
them don't yeah click it's really fun to
watch man it really is and what's also
cool and and that's that's the approach
you know it's funny we took yesterday um
is that you know yesterday was just good
for fans of basketball and fans of
talent and i thought
it's it's you know um my man jeffrey
osborne uh ltd concentrate on you you
know famously saying it takes separation
to bring appreciation
and i i was
i missed kyrie i missed watching him do
his thing i mean look man there there
are better scorers
in nba history there are better point
guards in nba history they're better
players in nba history but i'll be
damned that there is anybody who is more
gifted
at putting the ball in the basket more
creative at putting the ball in the
basket than kyrie irving he's so good he
is so
good and that's the and that's the thing
that we saw last night and i think for
the most part we'll see this will come
to a head
and i just can't imagine him sitting on
the bench
watching
his teammates compete for a championship
uh knowing what a difference
he could make um
yeah i'm with you man it does get
exhausting
it definitely gets exhausting and
unfortunately uh
it keeps finding its way back into the
conversations even in places that we
don't expect which i won't uh i won't
say anything else about that before my
blood pressure shoots up again like it
did yesterday michael smith thanks for
the time have a good one with michael
holly we'll we'll chat again next week
appreciate you thank you i got you
michael smith on brother from another
that follows the show on nbc sports on
peacock hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here